aurore bergé installez-vous bonsoir on
vous accueille au milieu des champignons
ce n'était pas le sujet de la discussion
de ce soir on va plutôt parler politique
avec vous pendant que je laisse notre
invité valérie jouve et sa compagne est
notre invité je vous laisse reprendre
aussi vos champignons voilà le monde
même aux invités de vous aider
formidable j'ai même reprendre les notre
valérie qui nous a tout laissé sur son
plateau merci valérie voilà donc on va
parler politique avec vous au port bergé
bonsoir militante ump depuis vos 16 ans
cela fait donc neuf ans aujourd'hui elle
chargée de mission auprès de la
fédération des yvelines très actif
durant la campagne législative de
valérie pécresse
vous êtes à présent engager pour
françois fillon pour qu'il soit élu le
18 novembre président de votre parti
vous avez aussi été la porte parole des
jeunes populaires la frange jeune de
l'ump 16 30 ans et vous pourriez
peut-être prétendre à sa présidence dans
les prochains mois on parle aussi de
vous pour les municipales en 2014 à
magny les hameaux ce qui fait beaucoup
de sujets sur lesquels on va discuter ce
soir est déjà un mot sur cette campagne
entre françois fillon et jean françois
copé est ce que cette campagne n'est pas
trop longue
déjà alors c'est vrai que la campagne
est longue mais en même temps je crois
qu'elle était nécessaire c'est à dire
qu'on sort d'un échec à la
présidentielle
le législateur se fiant et c'est
compliqué même si dans les yvelines
ça c'est quand même relativement bien
passé on a très bien résisté dans ce
département
donc je crois que les adhérents les
militants et même les électeurs de l'ump
avait envie qu'on leur parle qu'on aille
à nouveau vers eux et on le voit les
salles de meeting notamment je fais
celle de françois fillon sont pleines à
craquer et donc les gens viennent et son
enquête justement de réponse par rapport
à la manière dont l'ump va s'organiser
dans les prochains mois les prochaines
années pour aller vers la reconquête
juste le même un mot en ce moment on
parle beaucoup d'élections
présidentielles mais du côté des états
unis
forcément on parle d'obama romney vous
êtes déçus quel sentiment vous avez de
voir que cette campagne en france même
si c'est une campagne interne pour la
présidence d'un parti passionne moins en
ce moment et qu'on se préoccupe plus de
ce qui se passe aux etats-unis dont ne
pas mettre sur le même plan une élection
interne pour la présidence du débat la
discussion la campagne est entre
parenthèses ou pas est-ce que les noms
la campagne et pas du tout entre
parenthèses pour se fiant est en meeting
tous les soirs valérie pécresse
également son équipe de campagne
mobilise et nous ça nous arrête pas du
tout après les médias
et zap énormément et les sujets que vous
avez fait très régulièrement je pense
que la semaine prochaine quand on sera
dans le sprint final vous allez revenir
à temps par des assauts soir sur le
plateau et hier on parlait de l'élection
américaine également comme quoi alors
expliquez nous ce soutien à françois
fillon pourquoi ce choix de sauter
françois fillon pourquoi françois fillon
parce que je pense qu'on a besoin
d'apaisement et de rassemblement au sein
de l'ump on a subi des échecs
il faut qu'on en tire des leçons qu'on
arrive à comprendre pourquoi les gens se
sont détournés de nous et ne nous ont
pas fait confiance pour un second mandat
présidentiel
j'étais très engagé pendant cette
campagne est la défaite a été très
violent d'autant plus violentes qu'on a
eu un engagement énorme de la part des
militants et de la part de notre
candidat on a eu des législatives
contrastées qu'on a au final quand même
perdu donc un nom si on se remet pas en
question et si on n'est pas en capacité
de rassembler l'ensemble de la droite et
du centre
on n'arrivera pas à reconquérir que ce
soit pour les municipales ou que ce soit
par la suite pour les présidentielles et
les législatives
on va continuer à discuter justement de
vos motivations pour ce soutien françois
fillon juste une petite série de
questions au oui/non
c'est très rapide serez vous candidate à
la présidence des jeunes populaires en
cas de victoire de françois fillon
elle appelle week-end non à ben alors
c'est mal je dis oui ou non et bien
peine me peine on verra déjà moi le
principal objectif que j'ai c'est de
faire élire françois fillon le 18 nov
tout cas vous le dit pas mais je ne dis
pas non je ne dis pas oui mais je dis ce
ballon on retient aussi tu as fillon est
ce que vous serez candidate aux
municipales de magny les hameaux en mars
2004 alors même réponse alors oui mais
c'est perdu
évidemment je suis très impliquée à
magny les hameaux c'est une évidence
voilà je suis très impliqué dans le
réseau associatif on a recréé aussi une
dynamique au sein de l'ump on a eu un
jeu le maire qui a démissionné en faveur
dans ses adjoints en disant lui-même
je démissionne pour laisser la place
parce qu'ils ont besoin de préparer les
prochaines élections
je sens que la droite se réveille à
manille et donc il faut laisser la place
à mon nous
mon successeur pour la campagne je pense
que c'est finalement un hommage à la
dynamique on essaye de recréer sur manu
de dire que la droite se réveille donc
évidemment je suis pour quelque chose je
pense donc vous ne dites pas non je n'ai
pas serment quand même clairement pas
non à l'a clairement pas dans mon cas on
se rapproche d'un wii ou d'un nom est le
figaro madame qui a fait un portrait de
vous en février de cette année qui vous
définissez comme infatigable est ce que
c'est un terme qui vous convient oui ou
non la wii la wii ce qui nous regarde
une dernière question est ce que vous
souhaiteriez que nicolas sarkozy se
prononce entre françois fillon et jean
françois copé
j'aurais aimé oui mais je pense que
c'est c'est pas son échéance c'est pas
son sujet aujourd'hui
et puis là peut-être un autre parcours à
faire et on verra surtout quelle sera sa
position par rapport aux présidentielles
en classe et le silence actuellement
dans cette campagne je crois qu'il faut
arrêter de faire dire à nicolas sarkozy
ce qu'il ne dit pas essayer
d'interpréter ces absences ou ses
présences il est à la place qu'il a
choisi d'être en ce moment il faut la
lui laisser il faut respecter son temps
à lui
et puis laissons faire les candidats et
leurs équipes pour le reste alors si
nicolas sarkozy ne se prononce pas jean
sarkozy par contre qui s'est prononcé
qui s'est prononcé en faveur de jean
françois copé
vous en pensez quoi je pense que jean a
une parole libre que c'est un élu de
terrain et qu'il se prononce en tant que
lui-même et non en tant que son père il
faut au moins reconnaître
forcément on fait le lien forcément on
fait le lien mais dans ces cas là on
peut le faire par exemple est claude
guéant qui a été un des plus proches de
nicolas sarkozy et qui soutient
aujourd'hui françois fillon veut faire
avec christian estrosi et d'autres
soutiens g avec henri bedimo et on peut
le faire avec henri guaino pour jean
françois copé
donc si vous voulez on peut essayer
d'interpréter comme ça des signaux
permanent donné par nicolas sarkozy
encore une fois je pense qu'il faut le
respecter et le respecter c'est accepter
la place qui est la sienne aujourd'hui
vous soutenez donc françois fillon on
l'a bien compris vous le soutenez tout
comme valérie pécresse qui vous a
beaucoup aidé beaucoup lancer dans cette
carrière politique
c'est aussi dans cette idée de la suivre
partout toujours c'est pour ça que vous
souhaitez
alors j'espère quand même être un
minimum indépendantes autonomes c'est
sûr que je suis proche de valérie
pécresse c'est une femme que j'admire
j'admire le son courage admire son
parcours j'admire sa ténacité et c'est
sûr que là où elle est j'ai envie d'y
être et j'ai envie de la soutenir et de
l'accompagner donc évidemment que ça a
joué aussi dans mon soutient françois
fillon valérie pécresse député des
yvelines on va avoir une série de photos
vous n'avez pas été très forte au jeu du
oui ou non on va voir si vous êtes plus
forte avec ce jeu là on va voir juste
une série de photos ça s'affichera jeu
sur l'écran en face de vous et tout
simplement je vous demanderai un mot
pour réagir et qualifier les
personnalités politiques qu'on voit on
commence avec la première photo la photo
de jean françois copé un mot pour le
définir un mot clivant seconde photo
celle de françois fillon
rassembleur et toutes dernières photos
celle de valérie pécresse un mot pour la
définir admiration je regarde tout ce
que voulait dire sur jean françois copé
clivant ça c'est fort comme terme
en fait j'ai repris pour être
raisonnable de terme car employés
françois fillon à l'égard de jean
françois copé
j'ai beaucoup d'admiration pour jean
françois copé c'est une évidence un
animal politique il a une carrière
extraordinaire et ce qu'il a fait à
meaux est remarquable mais je trouve que
dans cette campagne il manque d'esprit
de rassemblement je suis à droite
clairement je sais pas s'il faut
qualifier cette droite d'humaniste de
libéral de décomplexer de libéral je
suis à droite et je pense qu'on a pas
besoin d'ajouter tous ces qualificatifs
et que après tout la droite et notamment
sur nicolas sarkozy n'était pas très
complexe et je pense pas qu'elle ait
besoin d'être des complexes aujourd'hui
je pense que l'ump a besoin d'être
rassemblée
encore une fois est-ce que le sujet
c'est de faire 30 % des suffrages ou est
ce que c'est de faire 51% des suffrages
s'il faut faire 51% et c'est le but d'un
parti politique je pense qu'on y
arrivera avec françois fillon on a
beaucoup de sujets abordés avec vous
roar bergé mais on va conclure sur cette
campagne pour la présidence de l'ump
on va écouter un extrait de jean
françois poisson qui était présent sur
ce plateau
il ya quelques semaines pour parler de
son soutien à jean françois copé jean
frédéric poisson par dont il est le
député de la 10e circonscription des
yvelines et qui était il ya quelques
semaines sur ce plateau on les écoute je
pense qu'il a envie de faire ce métier
là si je peux appeler ça un métier qu'il
peut y avoir des ambitions nationales
bien sûr et françois fillon a évidemment
les qualités pour être un
bon candidat à la primaire 2017 mais ça
n'est pas le sujet que nous avons à
traiter aujourd'hui lorsque vous faites
ça choix justement des jean françois
copé vous vous projetez pour fils
tellement c'est en 2010 est non ce n'est
pas ce qui nous est demandé ce n'est pas
le choix que je fais je ne présume pas
de ce que sera l'attitude que j'ai le
ferait dans cinq ans quand il faudra
désigner notre candidat à la primaire
pour la présidentielle si jamais nous
avons un candidat désigné dans une
primaire
moi je regarde l'occupation le travail
que va devoir faire celui qui sera à la
tête de notre famille politique pendant
les trois ans qui viennent 3 en passant
trois ans et ce travail là je pense
jean-françois copé a envie de le faire
il a envie de le faire d'une manière qui
me convient donc pour ces trois raisons
c'est une fiction alors berger est ce
qu'elle gens comme jean frédéric poisson
lorsque vous soutenez ce candidat c'est
françois fillon l'occurrence vous ne
pensez pas à 2017 honnêtement non je
pense aujourd'hui qui est le plus en
capacité de faire gagner l'ump d'abord
pour les municipales et qu'il plus en
capacité de faire de l'ump un vrai parti
de masse où les militants seront formés
ce qui veut créer une école des cadres
et pour le court un moment il faut pas
non plus se tromper d'élection c'est
vrai c'est évident que ce soit jean
françois copé ou françois fillon ils ont
d'autres ambitions et l'un et l'autre
est celui qui sera président l'ump aura
un avantage sur l'autre on va pas se
mentir
maintenant aujourd'hui quand je fais le
choix de françois fillon jean fait le
choix pour être le président de l'ump
après on aura des primaires ouvertes
alors françois fillon qui a été le
premier à se prononcer pour mon des
primaires socialistes qui étaient
décriée parfois à droite
donc on aura des primaires ouvertes si
on verra à ce moment là quels en seront
les candidats
on l'a vu à chacun des ténors à l'ump a
choisi son camp est ce que les divisions
vont pas être trop forte aussi au
lendemain le 19 novembre le matin
lorsque le président de l'ump sera
désigné ce qu'il sera possible de se
rassembler il faudra se rassembler en
fait la question se pose même pas on
n'aura pas le choix c'est une exigence
plus rassemblement et pour le coup franc
sociaux encore une fois le démontre dans
sa campagne dans les panels de soutien
qui là qu'il est en capacité aujourd'hui
d'être le meilleur rassembleur donc je
suis persuadé qu'il sera le garant de ce
rassemblement
s'il gagne le 18 novembre au soir pour
que dès le 19
on travaille également avec jean petit
et c'est le gagne pas parce que vous
serez derrière jean françois copé mais
je suis derrière l'ump
moi ça fait jaser pas derrière la sphère
privée donc celui qui gagnera
avant je soutiendrai moi j'ai adhéré à
l'ump j'avais 16 ans donc c'est pas
aujourd'hui presque dix ans après que je
vais me dédire mon engagement il est à
l'ump il est à droite
et évidemment je continuerai mon
engagement et une fois cette élection
terminé il faudra se pencher sur une
autre un autre scrutin celui pour les
jeunes populaires n'y a pas de date
encore qui était fixée normalement de
scrutin aurait déjà dû d'ailleurs se
tenir il a été repoussé et vous nous
disiez tout à l'heure que vous vous
étiez pourquoi pas par tendre pour être
candidate pour cette présidence d des
jeunes populaires de la frange des 16-30
ans de l'ump ça vous intéresserait
véritablement ce poste vous aviez déjà
été candidate alors j'avais déjà été
candidate en effet j'ai été pendant deux
ans porte parole national des jeunes
populaires la question elle se posera
très honnêtement après le 18 novembre et
tout dépendra aussi du candidat qui aura
qui aura gagné la présidence de l'ump
aujourd'hui elle se pose pas c'est un
job on va dire qui est passionnant parce
que c'est en comment organiser en grande
partie la re conquête on allant dénicher
les nouveaux talents parmi les 16 30 ans
pour les prochaines municipales et de
l'eau ici on pense aux cantonales aux
régionales de 2015 donc évidemment que
ce sera un très beau challenge
et en plus c'est la première fois au
sein de l'ump qu'on en position d'être
dans l'opposition justement est donc
également au sein des jeunes comment
nous on arrive à se positionner en étant
aujourd'hui opposant ce qui ne nous est
jamais arrivé
à chaque fois on a demandé aux jeunes de
soutenir l'action du gouvernement l'a
pour la première fois on va nous
demander d'être les meilleurs opposants
à la politique de françois hollande
donc je pense que en effet ce sera un
mandat une fonction qui sera très
intéressante si françois fillon
l'emportent
valérie pécresse devient secrétaire
général de mu mais ce sera un plus pour
vous forcément dans le cadre d'une
candidature c'est pour ça que j'attends
plus qui gagnera et faire je reviens
juste sur la campagne que vous aviez
déjà mené septième campagne difficile
pour cette présidence c'était une joie
est difficile c'est en 2010 oui donc
face à benjamin lancar qui est l'actuel
donc prévient que j'ai raison vous ont
gardé un bon souvenir de cette campagne
j'en garde quand même un très bon
souvenir quand même parce que c'était
difficile quand vous perdez enfin on
vous dit quand même si elle gagne la
campagne avait été difficile aussi parce
qu'elle avait été dure entre les entre
les différents candidats
oui mais honnêtement on n'est pas
enfin le but c'est pas singer nos aînés
et c'est pas d'être parfois plus
caricaturaux que honnêtement qu'on voit
jean françois copé françois fillon on
arrive à avoir un débat de qualité entre
les deux donc si au niveau des jeunes on
en devient plus caricaturaux et plus
véhémence pas forcément très malin donc
non évidemment c'est une campagne que
j'ai perdu donc c'est ça reste quand
même un bon souvenir d'avoir fait cette
campagne a trait à la rencontre des
militants d'avoir conduit une liste
j'avais le soutien en plus de certains
nombre de parlementaires donc c'est sûr
que c'est une campagne qui reste un bon
souvenir
il ya une autre élection forcément qui
est un peu plus vous intéresse peut-être
un peu plus
c'est cette élection municipale du côté
de magny les hameaux au delà l'élection
de françois fillon
on l'a bien compris mais c'est cette
élection du côté magny les hameaux vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure le départ
de jacquelot lloze le maire socialiste
qui s'est retirée de ce poste de maire
de la ville au profit de bertrand ou son
adjoint et vous critiquer cette position
d'ailleurs une partie de l'opposition
l'opposition ump sur la ville de manière
mot n'était pas présente lors de
l'élection du successeur de jacquelot
lloze vous approuvé cette position de
l'opposition basé sur les enjeux
travaillent main dans la main avec
l'opposition municipale donc c'est une
décision qu'on a prise ensemble de dire
est ce que parce que vous ne sais pas je
n'étais pas candidate aux dernières
municipales
est ce que oui ou non on va siéger
pendant cet adoubement c'est pas une
élection c'est un adoubement
et ce petit arrangement entre amis en
gros c'est ça c'est le maire sortant qui
était en plus candidats aux législatives
la dernière fois qui souhaite s'en aller
de lui-même et clairement il le dit
c'est pour mieux préparer les
municipales
je sens je le cite que la droite se
réveille à manille donc je préfère
laisser mon successeur
pendant un an et demi pour qu'il prépare
au mieux les municipales est ce que
vraiment l'opposition de droite et c'est
là pour cautionner ça honnêtement c'est
un petit arrangement entre amis
très bien ils l'ont fait à bertrand
vient de faire ses preuves en tant que
mère désormais pendant un an et demi
et puis la vérité à l'élection et ce
jour en mars 2014 et là ce seront les
électeurs à manille qui décideront et ce
sera pas un petit arrangement sein du
conseil municipal
le fait qu'un maire en poste se retire
au profit d'un adjoint pour une élection
municipale
c'est quelque chose que vous ne
connaissent cautionnez pas c'est ce que
vous nous expliquer et ça dépend des
contextes mais encore faut-il annoncé
que la vie justement développer les
loisirs par exemple de l'annoncé en
amont par exemple du côté de plaisir je
regnault le maire de la ville maire ump
a décidé de se retirer juste et par là
même au psg c'est bien qu'ils ont
préparés face à une opposition et de
gaulle avant le coup on le savait
c'était préparé c'était annoncé on
savait qu'il n'irait pas au bout de son
mandat
quand jean paul ii était présente en
deux minutes à aucun moment il n'a
laissé entendre qu'ils n'iraient pas au
bout de son mandat
quand il a été candidat aux législatives
face à valérie pécresse et qu'il a perdu
à aucun moment il n'a laissé entendre
qu'ils n'iraient pas au bout de son
mandat dans sa profession de foi il
disait même à quel point il a été
attaché à son territoire sans préciser
que c'était sa dernière une politique
dernière campagne politique ça veut pas
dire que vous n'avez pas au bout du
mandat qui vous a été donné je pense
qu'une différence entre ce que fait joël
regnault à plaisir ou là c'était a lancé
c'était su et tout le monde savait en
effet qu'il passerait la main en cours
de mon set et ça a été une surprise tout
de même cette annonce on s'y attendait
honnêtement un plaisir on s'y attendait
et là à manille où clairement ils se
disent bon on pensait que la droite très
moribonde
on pensait en effet qu'on n'aurait pas
d'opposition on pensait qu'il serait pas
en capacité de présenter une liste qui
peut nous battre en 2014
là il voit clairement que nous sommes
une équipe que nous y travaillons et que
nous ferons tout pour présenter un
projet alternatif à manille et pour
faire battre l'équipe actuelle donc ils
ont envie de se remobiliser pour cette
élection il se dit qu'en effet le
meilleur moyen c'est d'installer pendant
un an et demi déjà le nouveau maire donc
ça veut dire que ce sera plus difficile
vous auriez préféré être en opposition
face à jacques lognos par exemple grâce
à bertrand guillon c'est pas à nous de
choisir c'est au parti socialiste de
désigner le candidat qui sera face à
nous
c'est pas à nous de choisir jacquelot
liauzu bertron lyon moi une autre équipe
à avoir une préférence dans l'optique
d'une victoire plus ou moins facile
aucune préférence
on va l'écouter bertrand oui on était
également sur ce plateau il ya quelques
semaines il réagit c'est donc à cette
élection à son conseil municipal
et puis à l'échéance de 2014 sur cette
ville le passage de témoin en cours de
route
et justement de la part de jacques los
dioses déjà un acte de courage parce que
c'est
c'est très rare que des zébus déjà bien
établie dans leurs fonctions choisissent
de passer la main
nouvelle génération et puis et puis à
côté de ça le fait qu'il soit absent ce
soir là finalement me fait un peu penser
à un électeur qui n'irait pas voter 2014
est une étape mais une étape logique
dans nos institutions qui lui fait
absolument pas peur et qui nous fait pas
peur donc sur laquelle on se mettra pas
forcément de pression de pression
particulière
en face à priori je sais qu'il ya
certaines velléités mais qui viennent se
présenter et puis c'est ça le jeu
démocratique juste en moi je les
sereinement
il est serein cette semaine c'est fini
de présenter ses réelles et très
souriante et si vous présentez ce serait
en tête de liste
lien on verra on est beaucoup dans la
prospective c'est pas le temps de
l'annoncer c'est juste ça mais je vous
promets que vous serez les premiers
informés
la composition de la liste municipale de
magny les hameaux et vous viendrez sur
ce plateau donc plaisir pour en parler
on va continuer à discuter avec vous on
va parler d'un autre sujet plus générale
cette fois ci c'est l'engagement féminin
en politique il ya un livre que vous
avez écrit avec deux autres femmes
engagés en politique également notamment
une c'était au parti socialiste
alter égale un livre d'entretiens sur
l'état du féminisme en france et la
représentation des femmes en politique
quel état des lieux vous faites tout
simplement honnêtement il n'est pas très
bon nous on a essayé de faire un livre
qui était pas partisan donc on est trois
jeunes femmes deux engagés à l'ump une
au parti socialiste on a eu envie de se
retrouver sur un sujet qui est souvent
très peu traité on en traite un petit
peu pendant les campagnes
présidentielles parce qu'il ya toujours
le 8 mars est la journée de la fin mai
donc on donne des roses à la fin d'un
meeting
et puis après on oublie les engagements
qui ont été pris
aujourd'hui évidemment il est question
des femmes en politique mais bien au
delà de ça il ya toutes les autres types
de violences qui sont faites aux femmes
c'est à dire les écarts de salaires qui
restent très important le fait qu'
évidemment les femmes sont tenus à
l'écart du marché du travail parce que
on n'appuie pas suffisamment de places
en crèche par exemple et qu'on préfère
qu'elles prennent un congé parental qui
les éloigne durablement du marché du
travail
les violences physiques faites aux
femmes et enfin je pense qu'il faut
quand même arriver là le rappeler
régulièrement
aujourd'hui une femme qui meurt tous les
deux jours et demi sous les coups de son
conjoint de son compagnon c'est pas
juste que une marque qu'il faut le dire
et d'ailleurs faut peut-être arrêter de
le dire mais voir ce qu'on peut faire
pour lutter contre ça et puis évidemment
la place des femmes en politique
alors là c'est vrai qu'on a un
gouvernement paritaire et c'est une
bonne chose nicolas sarkozy et elle est
aussi assez loin avec des femmes qui
étaient notamment ministère de
l'intérieur mais serge affaires
étrangères ministère qu'on allait porter
à melgven pendant les élections
légistatives pour autant il était
difficile d'avoir des listes paritaires
et d'avoir aussi des femmes qui soient
une fois pas suppléante parce que
c'était souvent présente en tant que
suppléant autant sur le liste que ce
soit l'ump d'ailleurs comme sur les
autres blessés à un bon mot qu'on se
disait on l'a dit d'ailleurs pendant les
cantonales le féminin de candidat c'est
suppléante
mais c'est assez vrai malheureusement
politique parce que tous les partis
enfin en tout cas les partis établis et
qui ont énormément d'élus savoir le
partialité l'ump préfère aujourd'hui
payer des amendes plutôt que d'avoir des
listes paritaires bien aujourd'hui je
vois par exemple à l'ump
si on avait présenté des listes
paritaires et bien on aurait aussi plus
de moyens financiers pour exister à
cause de ça à cause du non respect de la
loi l'ump perd 4 millions d'euros de
dotation annuelle est ce que c'est bien
perçu justement au sein de l'ump lorsque
vous évoquez cette question qui fait pas
forcément plaisir à certains cadres mais
ça fait jamais en fait la question c'est
moins la question de la parité que la
question du renouvellement politique
donc forcément quand il ya une nouvelle
tête qui émerge croyait du
renouvellement qui doit avoir lieu
ça fait jamais plaisir à ce qu'ils
soient en place parce qu'ils disent que
c'est eux qui vont devoir laisser la
place
j'espère juste que le jour où nous on
sera en capacité le jour où nous on sera
parlementaires élus on n'agira pas de la
même manière et qu'on acceptera plus
facilement ce renouvellement est ce
livre altéré galles qui est en
compétition pour le prix edgar faure qui
sera remis le 4 décembre on vous tiendra
bien évidemment au courant des résultats
puisque nous parlons de l'engagement des
femmes en politique nous sommes allez
vous poser cette question aujourd'hui à
saint quentin en yvelines trouvez vous
qu'il y est assez de femmes en politique
alors oui je pense qu'il ya cette
fameuse politique enfin le nombre en
fait augmenté ces dernières années donc
c'est une bonne chose pour elle et c'est
avec maintenant je crois qu'il ya eu à
peu près une femme sur cinq qui est
député ça m'est complètement égal
voilà donc pour moi c'est pas grave
pourquoi pour juste d'un problème
d'équité simplement pour remettre
l'equilibre à l'équilibré des masses la
plus d'hommes que de femmes ça a
toujours été je pense que les femmes
n'ont pas forcément de mauvaises idées
non plus en politique
aumônerie nord encore un petit peu plus
je préférerais quand même oui
certainement mais un peu plus parce que
bas nous les femmes on sent plus près
les fans de toute façon et puis je pense
qu'elles elles peuvent à mon avis je
sais pas nous donner beaucoup plus
davantage qu'on a jusqu'à maintenant
ben je devais clients sur maman papa on
va pas se plaindre à y en a quand même
pas mal
je ne suis pas particulièrement pour les
quotas je pense que chacun doit faire
comme il a envie et ce qu'il sait faire
non pas suffisamment non au niveau des
entreprises ça évolue donc il faut
espérer qu au niveau de la politique
c'est suivent c'est surprenant mais les
avis sont partagés
attention non mais ce qui est marrant
c'est le premier avis en disant c'est
bien pour elle qu'un n'est plus mais
c'est pas juste bien pour les femmes qui
est une représentation qui soit
égalitaire c'est bien pour la société si
on en doute les plus de gens ici qui
participent à des élections encore
faut-il que nos élus nous ressemble et
c'est la question la diversité aussi la
diversité non seulement ethnique on va
dire mais aussi sociologique on a
aujourd'hui les mêmes les mêmes
professions qui se représente à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
vu par rapport aux femmes on a en effet
à peu près qu'un cinquième de femmes
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée au sénat un
peu mieux au sénat est ce que c'est
vraiment suffisant je suis pas sûr
aurore bergé militant très engagé à
l'ump qui est l'invité ce soir du 7 8 on
va marquer une pause et on va
s'intéresser aux rapports gallois le
rapport gallois je voulais évoquer lors
des titres qui a été remis aujourd'hui
au gouvernement entre hausse de la tva
transfert des charges sociales crédit
d'impôt le point sur les principales
annonces également sur les réactions
dont le département
anthony rege gianasso dry guillon quand
c'est patrick jacques de dixmude alors
que le premier ministre jean-marc
ayrault allait annoncer les principales
mesures de son pacte de compétitivité
les chefs d'entreprises implantées à
promo paul nous ont livré ce matin leur
première réaction face aux rapports
louis gallois dévoilé la veille
pas créer de l'emploi en réduisant les
charges par le crédit d'impôt voyons
c'est complètement aberrant et ça peut
ça y est c'est la même teneur que le
rapport attali et personnes en tient
compte et quand vous êtes nous ont fait
beaucoup d'export quand vous discutez à
l'étranger notamment en europe
ils comprennent pas du tout les italiens
ont pris le problème par le bon bout
c'est-à-dire à réduire les dépenses
publiques de façon drastique et sérieuse
les propositions de apparemment de
monsieur gallois sont bonnes mais mr
envers le gouvernement
le rapport gallois semble bien
accueillie la réaction du gouvernement
attendu avec circonspection
il faut aider les jeunes entreprises à
pouvoir investir à pouvoir
j'irai éclore et progresser donc tout ce
qui pourra aller dans ce sens là ça sera
bien faciliter le financement facilité
je dirais tout ce qui peut toucher ou à
la croissance des entreprises ce sera
toujours utile maintenant
maintenant je dirais c'est à
gouvernement de faire ses propres choix
et après on verra une fois qu'ils se
seront exprimés pour relancer la
compétitivité et l'emploi le
gouvernement aura retenu le crédit
d'impôt qui permettrait une baisse de 6
% des cotisations patronales le
gouvernement devra alors économiser 20
milliards sur trois ans il prévoit une
réduction des dépenses de l'état à
hauteur de 10 milliards
l'autre moitié sera comblé par une
hausse de la tva appliquée dès 2014 les
tpe et pme ne rejette pas la proposition
mais les chefs d'entreprises auraient
préféré une réduction immédiate et des
charges sociales plutôt que le crédit
d'impôt donc l'idée de donner un crédit
d'impôt des réductions de charges c'est
un non sens absolu parce qu'on va devoir
finalement avancé la trésorerie pendant
des années pour récupérer donc en 2000
treize éventuellement un crédit d'impôt
sur des dépenses supplémentaires qu'on
leur fait cette année alors c'est
vraiment une compétitivité maintenant
dont on a besoin de rien d'un coup
maintenant d'autres la trésorerie et non
pas de dépenser plus pour trouver les
petits trucs pour une compétitivité dans
prochain même son de cloche du côté du
medef
le gouvernement demande un rapport avec
des mesures simples qui peut être
immédiatement
on a l'impression qu'on a d'un grand
marchandage quand même parce que
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'on les payera en
déductions fiscales sur deux trois ans
l'impact ne sera pas produit
immédiatement et l'impact n'a produit
que dans deux ans trois ans donc je n'ai
pas de mauvaises mesures mais c'est une
demi mesure
derrière ce crédit d'impôt de 20
milliards le gouvernement héros
s'attaque au coût du travail souvent
décriée par les entrepreneurs français
la qualification des salariés reste un
gage de qualité sur le marché
international on a un petit peu de mal
je virais notamment lorsqu'on veut
accompagner nos clients dans les grandes
capitales asiatiques fait donc par
rapport à ça
cela dit il faut pas non plus se fait en
général et les ingénieurs français sont
très bons ingénieurs très bien formés
très motivés et très reconnue sur le
marché international du côté politique
benoît hamon ministre chargé de
l'économie sociale et solidaire craint
les effets de cette baisse massive des
charges sur les ménages selon le député
de la 11e circonscription des yvelines
ces 20 milliards d'euros amputé aux
cotisations sociales frapperait durement
le pouvoir d'achat des français
au sein de l'opposition la députée des
yvelines valérie pécresse estime que ce
crédit d'impôt reste un dispositif
injuste et inefficace
l'ancien ministre ump du budget y voient
un moyen de différer la baisse des
charges d'un an qui pénalisera l'emploi
voilà pour les réactions dans le
département après les différentes phases
annonces du gouvernement
or ben j'ai peut-être une réaction sur
ces mesures qui ont été annoncées
aujourd'hui ont une réaction sur la tva
pendant toute la campagne françois
hollande nous a dit qu'il fallait
surtout pas voter la tva anti
délocalisation et là ils vont essayer de
faire croire aux français que c'est donc
une bonne nouvelle finalement
d'augmenter la tva
donc c'était assez drôle de les voir à
faire ce jeu de passe passe merci aurore
bergé d'être venu sur le plateau je
rappelle que vous soutenez françois
fillon pour la présidence de l'ump que
vous briguerez est sans doute le poste
de maire
un mot est peut-être le poste de
présidente des jeunes populaires dans
les prochains mois le 7 8 est terminé
pour ce soir on se retrouve demain dès
18 heures en direct excellente soirée